khattar abou diab politologue et
spécialiste du moyen-orient
bonjour khattar abou diab
merci de répondre à nos questions sur
arte france lundi soir après avoir
remercié l'onu à michel aoun a plaidé
pour des réformes de l'organisation
onusienne
le président libanais a déclaré faire
état je cite de certaines déceptions en
raison de certains rêves et espoirs qui
ne se sont pas concrétisées à travers
l'onu à quoi est ce qu il fait référence
michel aoun bonjour avant tout je pense
il fait référence pas à la finul la
finale depuis 1978 fait tout pour
préserver la stabilité c'est le
frontières du liban mais il fait
référence plus tôt au problème des
réfugiés pour lui c'est l'obsession
l'obsession la présence de réfugiés
syriens au liban et je pense que l'onu
devrait obliger les réfugiés à revenir
chez bachar al assad
c'est ça son problème mais sinon l'onu
comme les autres institutions
internationales ont commencé à perdre
confiance c'était très notoire lors de
la double explosion de beyrouth
il n'y avait pas donc même tous les
toutes les aides ne passait pas par
l'intermédiaire de l'état libanais et
c'est l'institution par mais par
l'intermédiaire des orangers peut-être
elle c'est cette sorte de dédain mof de
confiance de la part de la communauté
internationale a été mal vu par le
président libanais le président libanais
a également demandé à l'onu
un peu l'onu face à une double aide aux
pays qui en ont besoin après les
explosions de beyrouth justement dont
vous venez de parler la crise économique
et sociale 1 qui sévit au liban le liban
fait évidemment partie de cette liste de
michel aoun pourtant l'onu a réduit
quelque peu ses troupes
du côté de beyrouth que peuvent faire
les nations unies et concrètement pour
aider le pays du cèdre
vous savez à propos de la finul c'est
comme toutes les notions de l'onu c'est
le fruit d'un compromis d'un consensus
les états unis avec pour soutenir israël
voulait même à les définir la vision de
la finul la france la russie et d'autres
pays auraient fusé mais comme compromis
il y avait réduction du rôle de la finul
mais il ya aussi une sortie d'un
éclaircissement si on veut de son mandat
il faut être clair nous 1960
né en 1982 ni en 1996 ni en l'an 2000 ni
en 2006 le la fine il n'a pas réussi à
interdire des conflits allons à grande
échelle entre israël à un moment donné
avec les palestiniens à un autre moment
avec as bonnart et pour cela
l'interrogation autour de son rôle elle
est légitime mais ça dépend aussi de
deux des acteurs les acteurs qui ne
respectent pas les notions de l'oni mais
d'autre part le lit à travers le fonds
monétaire international à travers les
autres institutions sont impliqués dans
l'aide au libor il y avait une aide
internationale
un suivi intéressant mais c'est vrai à
cause de la corruption au sein de l'état
libanais à cause de la demande de l'état
libanais la confiance est perdue et tout
ceci fait des ravages parmi les ravages
en fait causé par la double explosion
comme parle beaucoup de développement à
cause de l'impasse politique
imaginé après cette double explosion et
malgré l'initiative du président
français on est toujours au point zéro
il y avait un plan politique la
communauté internationale la france en
tête appelle à des changements profonds
au liban en contrepartie d'une aide
chantage ingérence ou tout simplement
bienveillance écouter ni chantage ni
ingérence
il faut dire les choses comme tel s'il
libanais ne parviennent pas et d'eux
mêmes ils peuvent pas attendre toujours
l'aide des autres où être des mondiaux
chez les autres au 1000 en 2018
c'est à dire en avril 2018 la france a
appelé à la tenue d'une conférence
appelée conférence cèdre et à l'époque
on a beaucoup de consacrer dead et des
primes pour le liban presque 10
milliards d'euros
mais il y avait comme contrepartie les
réformes depuis l'aurore depuis ce avril
2018 et maintenant nous sommes septembre
2020 rien n'est fait il y avait des
élections il y avait des gouvernements
il y avait une un mouvement
révolutionnaire et tout ceci n'a pas
bougé les lignes pour cela à travers
l'initiative de maquereaux il y avait
c'est que cette contrepartie
c'est-à-dire le rétablissement des aides
internationales
les retours en coopération avec les
formes de terrain social sont
conditionnés par le lancement des
réformes
c'est à mon avis quelque chose de normal
d naturel de
et pour cela il faut que les dirigeants
libanais la classe politique notre
problème peu cette classe politique ce
système politique libanais a expiré il
n'est plus valable
et c'est ça l'effort de problèmes au nez
droid et crise des systèmes profonde au
liban merci khattar abou diab d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes politologue spécialiste du
moyen-orient et donc du liban et en
attend
le discours tout à l'heure à nos menus
de michel aoun le président du libre